all right hey everyone
so welcome back um first up we've got
aditi talking about worst case
robustness in machine learning so take
it away
hi everyone thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and thanks everyone for
joining so today i'll be talking about
worst case robustness and machine
learning so this is going to be sort of
a high level overview on the different
kind of problems that we deal with when
we think about robustness and machine
learning and how some kind of bridge
between worst case and kind of average
case analysis could be useful to solve a
pretty much a practice still very open
practical question
so to make sure everyone's on the same
page i mean we've all seen really
impressive results with machine learning
in the past few years for example in
alphago gpt3 alpha fold and you know if
you're wondering what avocados in the
form of armchairs would look like ml can
generate and tell us today
but not just these eye-catching
impressive results but ml is also widely
used around us in many different
applications like the ones shown on the
screen
so what got me interested in robustness
is to kind of look at how well does
machine learning work in these real
world applications
here is an example from 2015 that
perhaps a lot of you are familiar with
where it was seen that facial
recognition systems did not work very
well on certain demographics for example
this issue received a lot of attention
and it's been a few years since then so
you'd hope that things are better now
but in 2020 we see that you know facial
recognition systems continue to make
such mistakes and this time a black
person was wrongly arrested
so i went back and saw what happened in
2015 how did they address this issue
and turns out that the fix they came up
with was to remove the word gorilla from
their captioning lexicon
so i guess it's no longer that
surprising that some of these systems
are still pretty broken
here's another example of self-driving
cars which again we've been hearing a
lot about but how good are self-driving
cars
unfortunately we find that self-driving
cars are actually not that great and
unfortunately tragically a woman was
killed where among other issues the
problem was that a machine learning
model failed to recognize a pedestrian
who was jaywalking because it was only
trained to recognize pedestrians at
crosswalks
i don't want to start this talk on a
very dark note so when i looked up for
errors i also found some funny things
like how a soccer game was ruined
because you know mistakes that a machine
learning model can make
so what we find is that current machine
learning systems are really brittle and
while they're very promising in terms of
like all the impressive results that we
have they're also quite brittle in the
current form
and as we use ml so widely in a lot of
applications around us and we're only
probably going to use it more and more a
quite important question to think about
is how do we make these systems robust
so let's look at the machine learning
pipeline and think about like you know
where this issue is coming from so
usually what we do is collect a data set
of examples
we split this into train and test and
then we train on the training data and
we evaluate on this held out test set
so this is what a lot of us are probably
familiar with and you know most
benchmarks empirically as well as
theoretically studied the setting
um and a lot of open questions and we
don't completely understand you know
this by any means
but if you look at performance in the
real world this is clearly insufficient
because what we really should be caring
about is this wide range of examples
that the model could encounter when it's
deployed
for example pedestrians who could be
jaywalking
and so very broadly like robust machine
learning tries to deal with the question
of how do we get good performance on a
wide range of examples even if a model
is only trained on a particular set of
you know particular distribution p
and especially we think about good
performance outside this training
distribution
um so just to give a few concrete
examples within the community when we
think about robustness so one example is
security where you know for example in
content filtering if you use a machine
learning application um people are going
to try to subvert the system and get
their content through and they're not
going to restrict themselves to the you
know training distribution so it's
important to think about performance
outside the training distribution here
and even if there are no adversaries for
example if you have self-driving cars or
healthcare it's really important to
think about all the boundary conditions
and the edge cases as well
another important aspect is you know
fairness across sub-populations because
in many applications whatever
distribution you've collected you're
training data from could encode biases
and it's important to go beyond that
okay so having kind of you know said the
broad uh
uh reasoning of why we should care about
robust machine learning i wanted to
think like more carefully about what's
the objective and like what changes
compared to standard machine learning
so we have this training data we you
know pick a model architecture and then
we optimize some training objective and
then we evaluate this model
so usually the training data like you
know some end data points from some
distribution p
and we evaluate on this objective which
is just like how well some model does on
new examples from the same distribution
p
i think about robustness one kind of
standard way to model this is like the
robust optimization framework where
instead of just looking at performance
on one particular distribution p we
define a ball around this distribution
and we look at how well a model does a
new example in the worst case around
this ball of you know distributions
around the training data
so instead of looking at performance and
just one distribution we look at how
well the model does the worst case over
a ball of perturbations around this
particular distribution
so
usually what happens is like you know
people
think we should just change the training
objective but what we see is actually
that a lot of these aspects like you
know from training data model
architecture evaluation all of these
change quite significantly when we care
about the robust objective as opposed to
the standard objective
i'll try to go over some of these
aspects in this talk
so if you look more carefully you know
the objective you see that there's kind
of this nice uh tension where you do
have to think about the worst case
because now we're looking at performance
not just on one distribution p but
really across all distributions within
this ball around the training
distribution
but at the same time we are still
anchoring around a particular
distribution so it's not just all inputs
but it's kind of still related to your
training distribution in some way
because if this weren't the case then
like there's no like there's no way the
model would work because like why should
it work on something completely
different so you're kind of constraining
it to be close to the distribution but
you still want to get something beyond
exactly the brittle performance on one
distribution
and so yeah so you know a lot of this
work is trying to reason about worst
case perturbations of somewhat realistic
instances and so kind of modeling this
theoretically can be quite interesting
and challenging because we want to
balance both these aspects
so in the first part of the talk i'll
focus on
the evaluation part and talk about how
like the worst case makes sense
challenging in terms of evaluation and
understanding if a model is actually
robust we'll see how we need kind of
guarantees on this worst case
performance to end what would otherwise
be an arms race when we try to make
models robust
in the second part i'll talk more about
the statistical part of like actually
thinking carefully about what are the
distributions you're trying to learn and
what could be the statistical challenges
in trying to learn classifiers that are
robust on these particular distributions
so with that i'll jump into the first
part of the talk on adversarial examples
which is a particular notion of
robustness
um so the setup
so i think the framework is pretty
intuitive and easy to understand so
instead of looking at just performance
on one particular input to the model you
want to do well on attacks that can
perturb these inputs
as an example this is a stop sign that a
machine learning model would correctly
classify as a stop sign
it turns out you can add small
perturbations for example you can add
these black and white graffiti like
stickers and the same model would call
it like a completely different class of
speed limits
as another example you could have a
sentence that is correctly classified as
toxic and by just like perturbing and
adding or introducing one typo you can
make it you know a different prediction
and so abstractly you have some input
and you define a set of perturbations to
this input and you want to make sure
that your model does well on all
perturbations and the way we model this
is to say that an adversary can protect
this input to any point within this set
and we want to make sure the model does
well so depending on how we define this
side we can get different kinds of
robustness for example this could be
stickers this could be typos
and a very commonly studied example is
the following the set of perturbations
which we'll use for the rest of the talk
as well
so here's an image of a lecture that if
you take any good classifier of trained
on like images from the internet today
would correctly classify as a lecture
but you can change each pixel by a
really small amount to get the image at
the bottom that still very much looks
like the same image and looks like a
lake show to you and i
but the same model would call it a
completely different class of laptop
so precisely the set of perturbations
that we'll see is like each pixel or
each feature can be changed by some
small quantity epsilon which is usually
small enough that the images are
imperceptibly similar
i think this is kind of an interesting
challenge to try to stop because it
shows how brittle these systems are
where something that's even
imperceptible can really change the
model's predictions and so clearly these
models are making predictions in a very
different way than we imagined them to
and this is an extremely well studied
problem and we still don't have a
complete solution and there are like
some fundamental challenges like for why
this is so hard and i'll talk about some
of these in this talk but it's pretty
like you know it's not great that even
on this a very simple and well-defined
situation of robustness we don't have a
good way to achieve this
let's now talk about evaluation and like
why we need to think more carefully of
how do you even check if the model is
actually robust
so here's a brief history and
adversarial examples so like like i said
there's been a lot of work in this space
like what do things look like
in 2013 they were you know discovered
where it was shown that small
perturbations can break systems
and the problem was not that we didn't
have ideas on how to solve this problem
in fact very quickly there were a bunch
of different ideas for defenses that
were proposed for example
distillation but the issue was that it
was really hard to say whether whatever
was proposed was actually robust or not
so for example very quickly it was shown
that this idea was actually not robust
because you can search for perturbations
more carefully and you can break these
systems so the problem was these it was
these you know ideas like defenses were
being
checked heuristically like whether they
work or not and if they were not done
properly you could quickly break them
it was not just distillation there were
so many other defenses which had a
similar problem for example there was a
claim in a you know in this paper that
you don't need to worry if you can see
the same image from multiple views or
angles and so on because you have
redundant information
and just like five days later this claim
was shown to be broken
and in
yeah in 2018 there's this really nice
paper from icml where seven different
defenses that were published in the
previous conference were broken by the
next deadline
and so this was kind of really
unsatisfying because we had a lot of
ideas on how to defend but the problem
was it was really not clear which of
them were actually working and all the
defenses that were proposed they
constantly kept getting
broken so so the issue here is because
you're not reasoning about the worst
case properly and so we try to think
about you know is there a way we can
actually get a guarantee on the worst
case performance and put an end to this
kind of an arms race between attacks and
defenses
i'll talk about how we it turns out that
it is actually possible to get a network
with guarantees on the worst case
performance and i'll talk about some of
the work that we did and the main ideas
involved in getting our networks with
guarantees on their performance
okay so
the main idea which probably seems very
you know straightforward to
theoreticians is that yes we should like
obviously bound performance of the worst
case attack
and so if we like you know write it
mathematically what we're saying is
since you're allowing perturbations and
you're looking at what happens when you
make perturbations you want to make sure
that the maximum loss that any adversary
could induce within this allowable set
of perturbations that loss has to be
smaller let's say that loss has to be
zero if actually the network is robust
at that particular point because
otherwise it's not because you can
always search and find a better
perturbation that would break your model
this is like a very reasonable
straightforward thing to do and so what
we should be measuring is like on what
fraction of the points are you actually
able to make sure that the or sorry the
robust error is basically what fraction
of the points there is a perturbation
where the loss can be high because then
the attacker could find that
perturbation and break your network
but the problem is that computing this
loss or computing this maximization over
this ball of perturbation is actually an
intractable computation problem for
particular function classes
and so this was kind of the reason why
the straightforward idea that we should
just compute this maximum loss is like
kind of hard to like actually do it
and so you know the most commonly used
models and factors are deep networks so
to get a sense of what that
optimization problem looks like so you
have an input that goes through all
these different layers and you get an
output
and what happens in each of these layers
is you have a matrix multiplication and
then you apply a non-linearity
so that's how the input gets transformed
to the output
and so now the question is then you
perturb some input how does the output
change
and as you can imagine because you have
these non-linearities this whole process
of going from the input to the output is
now a non-convex problem and this is a
non-convex optimization
for example the commonly used
non-linearity or activation function is
this rectified linear unit where you are
zero if it's less than zero and then
your x or like z uh
if it's greater than zero
so the issues when you have deep
networks you have these non-convex
issues like you you've run into a
non-convex optimization problem because
of these non-linearities
yeah
why do you care about
um if it's hard to find the worst case
perturbation
um
what then why do you care if you defend
against it like uh your your attacker is
also in real life polynomially bounded
right so why do you shouldn't you care
about defending against the uh the the
worst attack that can be found by a
polynomial time attacker
right yeah that's a good point so i
guess it depends on how you model the
incentives of the attacker in some
points they in some cases they only care
about one particular point that they're
trying to break so you can imagine that
they have a lot more resources for one
point so when you're trying to defend
you're kind of trying to defend more
globally so that's one kind of a
mismatch that could arise and i guess
the second thing is in from a practical
perspective it's really hard to think
about kind of what like where to draw
the line for what's like you know
achievable or this is not so i think
that's one of the reasons that it's hard
to say
so so if you but okay you have some
non-convex optimization problem but like
the conventional wisdom is non-convex
optimization is easy just do gradient
descent exactly so suppose i did that
um if i and then i get the resulting
supposedly robustified network except
they did gradient descent so i don't
really have any certified bounds on how
well i did can you break those yeah so
that's kind of what was happening in the
previous slide right so that's exactly
the kind of ideas people tried was like
to have heuristic attacks but like you
can just use a better heuristic and
break those models so but one successful
defense that have that kind of is
unbroken in the sense that it doesn't go
down to zero but it still drops if you
search more carefully is to do something
like you said uh is to do like gradients
with descent with a lot of restarts and
careful tuning of the step size and this
is the robust adversarial training the
madrid yeah exactly okay yeah but uh
even those things from like my pers like
you know from my experience like you can
reduce the
accuracy but like a few percent points
but just being really careful about your
heuristics so
okay but but effectively what would be
going on is you're trying to like you as
the attacker are just trying to do a bit
better a job of the optimization problem
than was done in training yeah yeah the
another kind of challenge is that you
could still like so i guess people
usually call this transfer but you could
train on your own surrogate model and
then try to attack that and then
sometimes it just observed that that
also works on like a different model as
well because kind of maybe
intuitively like these models are having
similar failure modes in terms of what
signals they pick up so that's again
something we don't completely understand
it's and it's hard to say like how so
you could end up having a surgery
optimization problem that's easier but
like somehow things still transfer
so that's another issue thanks yeah
yeah feel free to stop me and ask
questions at any point
yeah so like i guess we spoke a little
bit about this so like you know exact
verification is intractable and um at
that time like some of the combinatorial
approaches that you know for example
using smt solvers like uh modified for
neural networks only scale to about 100
nodes
um and you could use mixed integer
linear programming as well and they also
didn't scale very well so in contrast
the kind of networks that we care about
in practice have about like you know
hundreds and thousands of nodes and so
there's a huge gap between when you
could actually compute the worst case
attack and what we you know we're trying
to use in practice
so what could we do about this and so
the kind of key idea is that maybe
computing the exact uh worst case um you
know perturbation or loss is hard
but you could still get away with
actually just computing an upper bound
and being
conservative okay so if you had an upper
bound such that if you could say like
whenever this upper bound evaluated to
zero like the worst case loss is also
zero by definition and so we know that
this function is robust to all attacks
so that was kind of the idea that we
pursued and so you know pictorially so
suppose this is kind of what the worst
case loss looked like
you could consider some upper bound that
looked like this for example
and whenever this upper bound was zero
you knew that even the true objective is
zero and so you can say that yes the
network is definitely robust at these
points but you could be missing at some
points where actually the worst case
loss is zero but the bond is too low
and so you know going off of that like
we could measure the certified error
which is like what fraction of the
points
this is upper bound actually greater
than zero because those are only the
potentially points that the network
could get wrong everything else you know
that the network has to get right
so this is one way in which you can try
to avoid this arms race and like no
matter what the adversity does as long
as you have a you know
like a correct upper bound this would
give you something in practice
and so this allows us to give like kind
of certificates of performance which
says that if you use this upper bound
you can prove that no attack can get
error greater than like whatever
certified error you measure
so this is kind of the idea that we
pursued on trying to break this arms
race
so one way to get upper bounds is convex
relaxations that perhaps a lot of you
here are familiar with and we came up
with one upper bond so i'll present the
upper bound later like you know we had
some upper bound
where so like earlier we you know had
this issue that when you have
perturbations the outputs can trace this
non-convex set and so instead of dealing
with this thing that's hard to analyze
we have a convex set that surrounds all
these perturbations that actually come
from the valid set and you use duality
to make sure that you are getting a
right upper bound across this entire
convex set
that's sort of the idea that we employed
to try to get an upper bound and see
whether we could prove something about
how robust these networks are actually
in practice
and so i can go and try like you know
what happened to this upper bound and so
the kind of unbroken defense like like
in this i in that paper that broke seven
defenses out of it one thing that they
couldn't break very much was adversarial
training which like sam was saying the
idea is that you approximate the
gradient to the worst case loss and you
keep training and hopefully if you know
search carefully enough such that you
are got everything on the training set
and then it kind of generalizes
and so we kind of uh we computed what
are the points where this upper bound is
greater than zero and that gives you the
certified error
and when we did that what we found was
that we got something pretty vacuous so
this bound was so loose that it said
that every one of those points is
potentially attackable
and so we didn't really learn anything
because in practice it seemed like the
network was robust but we weren't able
to really say anything about it using
this particular convex relaxation
because it was too loose
this is slightly disappointing but at
the time we you know kind of went back
and thought like maybe this bound is
vacuous on that particular adversarially
trained networks
but could we find new networks where
this bond was actually meaningful so
maybe we can't prove something about
this network but can we get new networks
where this boundaries can be used
and so the idea we pursued was can we
train new networks or like have a new
training process that gave us a network
where whatever convex relaxation or
upper bound that we used was useful
enough to give you something reasonable
about the certified error
right so the you know the natural idea
is that instead of minimizing the
whatever heuristic that you had before
this minimizes upper bound directly and
so hopefully by minimizing this upper
bound you're forcing yourself to find
parameters f where this bond is small
and so that's what we did and we got
this kind of max
grad network
evaluating how well this did in practice
what we found is that now this you know
on this particular network this bond is
actually reasonable and so we got a
guarantee that no attack can get more
than 35 percent error
whereas in you know until then it like
it felt like when you had a defense the
network would just any attack could just
make it to zero but now we've got a
network with a guarantee using this idea
of upper bounds
so this is very interesting because you
know when we think about instances and
like finding instances that are easy to
solve this is one way in which that
actually played in practice in that you
have an upper bound that's not always
tight but like like let's try to find an
instance where the upper bound is tight
and because you have control over the
training process in many
you know many occasions you can try to
find a network where you can prove
things about
and so the key takeaway that we found
was like vacuous upper bonds actually
become non-vacuous when you minimize
them while training
and so that led us to this kind of new
way of thinking about defenses in that
instead of minimizing heuristics which
is what you typically do you instead
take an upper bound where you can prove
things are robust that bond might not be
tight always but well you can find a
network with that site by explicitly
minimizing that on your training set
um
and just to like you know give some
concrete numbers so mnist is a very
common data set in machine learning
where we want to predict uh which
digit like a handwritten digit it is
so usually you just measure on this test
set but now we introduce some
perturbations not sure if you can see it
but like there are some small
perturbations and you want to see how
well your network does on these
perturbations
and so you can compute a certified error
using the same idea by using the upper
bound but you get a guarantee on
performance
and so
you know using this idea of certified
defenses like this concrete work from
cmu with a slightly larger network and
the same idea so minimizing this upper
bound you're actually getting somewhat
reasonable certified errors as opposed
to the kind of arms rate that existed
earlier
and since then they've been like a lot
of work on using different bounds and
you know scaling things up differently
and pretty much we get like you know up
to two percent error uh with guarantees
as opposed to uh what existed before
um so just to like place things in
perspective so in 2013 like when these
adversarial examples were discovered
there was this uh kind of uh an arms
race between attacks and defenses and
like you know kind of one method that
stood out was this work from alexander
madre uh madrid's group where they used
a heuristic more carefully and it was
not broken but we had no guarantees on
whether it's going to be broken or not
when we tried to use smt solvers they
were didn't scale as well
and so instead of that instead of trying
to say something with adversarial
training we followed a different route
of having certified defenses where we
just trained new networks with the idea
that we want to certify them and so we
constructed some upper bounds and then
constructed a network where that upper
bound is meaningful
and yeah and so that was kind of you
know
uh how about the landscape look like at
that point and so since then there have
been a lot of successful applications of
this idea to get networks from many
different applications
but this question that we had earlier
about whether we can say anything about
these adversarially trained networks
which is kind of what was most popular
and easy to do at that time
we still didn't have an answer there
so this is something that we thought
could be interesting to think about
because in practice we might not always
know exactly what method we want to be
robust to or like what is the training
process and ideally we should be able to
say something about any reasonably
robust network for example that is
trained via some heuristics
so going back to that again so you know
the reason previous upper bounds failed
were that they were just too loose and
so we can think about can we get just
tighter upper bounds that yeah you know
would work on more networks
so um recall that this is the objective
what it looked like so we had to deal
with these non-linearities or activation
functions at each layer
so we try to get a tighter relaxation
using semi-definite programming that
i'll try to briefly talk about and since
it could be something that's interesting
to people here
and this is like this is just one
attempt that we made and would be very
interesting to get tighter bonds as well
so if we look at um
these non-linear activation functions
for example the value this is what this
is the most popular activation function
used and this is what it looks like
so the idea is that when we have this
max constraint you can really replace
this as the following equivalent
quadratic constraints right so
h greater than 0 and h greater than z
kind of make sure that you're always
greater than both this line and this
line
and the second sorry the third quadratic
constraint make sure that you're equal
to at least one of them
so these quadratic constraints are a way
to exactly encode this rectified linear
unit constraint here
we haven't simplified anything so far
like this is like the exact same
question
but the nice thing about writing it as
quadratic constraints is now we can you
know use semi-definite programming as a
very natural relaxation of these
quadratic constraints
and this is like such a large body of
work on sdp relaxation you know linked
like for example the max cut relaxation
and so the nice thing is that if you can
actually think about these activations
as quadratic constraints we can tap into
this large body of work on sdp is to try
to get relaxations
we kind of try to do that and perhaps a
lot of you here are thinking about you
know sdps don't scale very well as well
like i'll get to that in a bit but we
just tried to see whether there was any
promise in this idea of using sdp
relaxations to get guarantees on these
kind of non-linear activations
we took back this adversarial train
network which didn't have guarantees at
that time we took a moderately sized
network so it's like four layers like
2000 nodes it's not the biggest network
we use today but we wanted to see what
we can do
and all the previous certifiers if you
recall were basically vacuous because
the bonds were just so loose but they
were mostly based on linear programming
which were weird to lose
to say something unless you explicitly
minimize them
so we tried to see whether there's
something we could do with using
quadratic constraints instead
and when we use the sdp certifier we
found something pretty interesting that
now we actually got a pretty
non-backused result
so until then we didn't know anything
about like what's the exact error of
adversarial training but now we could
get a bond of 18 which says that no
attack can get error greater than 18
and it's pretty close to the lower bound
coming from our taxes okay not super
close but it's it's in the ballpark
so this is pretty promising to us
because if you use only linear
constraints and you could say nothing
about networks that were not explicitly
trained used to minimize that bound but
somehow using quadratic constraints
seems to be useful we can also prove
that for for example random instances on
and two layer networks like sdp
relaxations like improve your tightness
by square root dimension compared to
linear programming relaxation which is
what people were using
and so just a sanity check we looked at
taking different um you know different
other robust networks as well so it's
not just adversarial training we look at
certified networks as well and we saw
something pretty similar that on a
variety of these different networks this
sdp relaxation is pretty tight
and
so this led us to pursue like can we you
know can we use this as a way to get
meaningful certificates in practice for
a variety of networks which might not be
trained in any particular
fashion so the caveat is that sdps seem
to be tight as we verified in small
instances but they don't scale very well
for example we used off-the-shelf
solvers and like 2000 nodes was kind of
the limit at which we could use them but
the nice thing is that um there's a lot
of structure in deep networks and i kind
of wanted to share that in terms of
getting new efficient algorithms is that
we know how to do
first order methods really well with
deep networks for example a lot of the
current implementations they like they
are highly optimized for taking
gradients and training and network and
so like actually running first order
methods for example for sdp verification
can be reduced using the same primitives
that already are used for training the
network and so that means we can
actually run things in parallel like use
optimized implementations for example
for like convolutional matrices and so
on and there's actually a lot of
structure that could be employed instead
of solving these sdps for the purpose of
verification of neural networks
so we did a very kind of first pass at
this we literally took the simplest
first order you know reformulation you
could think of and just implemented that
using the idea that we only need it
forward and backward passes so which are
basically operations we have for
training networks
and this also allows us to integrate
into modern frameworks and so
in principle you can run this on any
network that you can train so that's
pretty scalable
and this just this very simple idea
allowed us to now scale up to 20 000
nodes and 2 million parameters which was
a huge factor of improvement over what
combinatorial solvers could solve
and so this allowed us to actually scale
up even more complex data sets like c410
and get guarantees on robustness
just to complete this picture uh you
know we asked this question can we say
something about adversarial training or
things that seem like they were useful
in practice
and
so there was this idea of using
quadratic relaxations and getting a
tighter sdp certification which scaled
till about 1000 nodes but by using first
order methods we're actually able to
scale it up further and get something
reasonable on networks with up to 20 000
nodes
so i just wanted to kind of reflect on
these results and say some open
questions away i think especially
theoretical insights could be useful and
we don't have answers so far
we go back to this idea of certified
training where we minimize upper bounds
on
robustness as a way to get certifiably
robust networks
one one thing that we observe in
practice is that that doesn't do as well
as using heuristics so somehow running
gradient based search and explicitly
minimizing the gradient based search is
much better at practice than actually
trying to get an upper bound and being
robust to this upper bound
so one issue could be that by minimizing
this upper bound we're kind of
regularizing too much and that we're
actually not allowing enough capacity so
that's intuitive and it's we don't have
a clean way of thinking about this and
so like when we are explicitly
minimizing some bond we are making
things easy to certify but in the
process like what exactly is effective
hypothesis class and is there some thing
we can say about how expressive those
classes are is that kind of what's the
issue when you say you don't do as well
you mean in inaccuracy like the
inaccuracy and robustness both
okay right so for example attacks can
get say these are just numbers at the
top of my head like an attack let's say
gets nine percent um on adversarial
train networks an attack could get like
15 on the certified network it's just
guaranteed to be 15 but it's still you
can still get that
yeah
so it's not just that the bond is loose
but the attack performance is also
different so like i think the networks
are actually less robust somehow and so
yeah so like i think i mean yeah i guess
the training error is also like
somewhat high for these networks and so
i think it's there is an issue of
expressivity when we use an upper bound
and so the question is like can we
design upper bounds that do not affect
expressivity uh that would be pretty
interesting and of course like you know
another thing that we haven't really
thought about is what is the role of the
data distribution so at some point the
network still comes from minimizing some
data so if we make some assumptions on
the data can we like come up with a
suitable upper bound such that putting
them together you're not compromising on
your performance
and these are things that we don't
understand and so and i feel like this
is we're kind of hit the ceiling in
terms of like how
well another interesting property we
found was that
if you use
uh loser upper bounds like for example
you don't even do linear programming you
just like propagate box constraints like
just a very simple thing you can do
but that allows you to like train things
for longer and train larger networks and
somehow they all come together to get
the same performance so if you use a
really complex upper bound you are
restricted in terms of how much you can
scale but if you use a simple upper
bound it's loose but like you can scale
it up and somehow they all get very
similar performance in practice there
seems to be like some kind of ceiling
that we don't really understand where
it's coming from
um
yeah sorry and then like in terms of
just general certification we don't
think about explicit training
the natural question is how do we get
tighter relaxations how do we get more
scalable relaxations and maybe sdps are
promising but like you know this is just
like one attempt i'd be really
interesting to think about better ways
to certify these problems
and also other some architectures are
initializations that can be better that
we have some guidance on what we can do
such that we are able to generally
certify things
um yeah the same question from before we
still don't know exactly how do we
incorporate statistical structure of the
training distribution in terms of like
what networks we care about and how do
we uh certify them in practice
okay so
with this i'm going to switch gears if
there's any questions on the previous
part i can take questions
yeah
um did you did you study a little bit
some statistics of the networks that you
were getting uh
when they were satisfiably robust
compared to uh networks that were
trained in a more
vanilla fashion
yeah so i mean
tried a bunch of things so like uh
things that come to my mind are when you
try to minimize upper bounds you find
that things are sparse much like they
activate like there are some nodes that
are just always off so when you actually
do the gradient based search that is not
true so somehow by using an upper bound
you're kind of inducing much more
sparsity than if you weren't using the
upper bound so that was one observation
that we found uh the other thing is the
weights are typically larger or like the
effective margin in the sense that like
the output by the norms are smaller when
you do adversarial training even on the
original instances so not just on
perturbation but even in the original
instances you do see that
but that's more related to the
generalization part maybe not as much as
like the statistics of the network but i
we didn't have any other like the
sparsity was the only thing that we
noticed was qualitatively different
okay because i guess intuitively you
have this sort of idea that uh
the
networks are trained normally uh
have this weird situation where you have
you know some
some uh
very quick variation that right you know
makes it that you go into another class
very quickly you have these sort of
tentacles
and so
this is not is this something that you
try to illustrate also a little bit with
seeing if this sort of phenomena is
something that happens
i i feel like i mean it's hard in some
sense the existence of these
perturbations kind of says something
similar like you know just the fact that
you have perturbations across the
boundary already intuitively get at that
um
yeah
i don't know if i don't i don't think i
have any other like concrete thing to
add there okay thanks
[Music]
cool
so with a better handle on evaluation
like you know we can go back and look at
how how we are actually making things
robust
um so let's look at a slightly more
complex benchmark
called c510 which is this
image classification data set so you
have 10 classes and you want to predict
which of the classes the images
you can measure the standard error which
is like what percent of the test set is
misclassified that's usually what we
measured
and we can also look at robust error
which is how well do things perform in
the presence of attacks so you take an
image you allow an address ready to
perturb it by some epsilon so that it's
still small and you see whether the
network can get it right
if you do standard training you do
pretty well on the test set so that's
why we all think machine learning is
great but things are not robust so for
this part of the talk just to keep
things simple let's just look at the
heuristic performance so adversarial
training
what we see is that the robust error
does improve and this is kind of a rough
like if you do certified error it will
be like worse than this so you do
improve
but interestingly though there's a
trade-off so you see that the standard
error
increases so somehow your robustness has
improved but your accuracy has gone down
and this is not true just for
adversarial training they've been you
know a lot of variations been proposed
and they also similar trend where your
robustness does improve but the standard
error of these robust models was like
four times higher than that of the
standard models
so this to me was very surprising
because like i felt like by making
things robust like you should strictly
be making the models better because
you're trying to force it to not use
meaningless perturbation but somehow we
actually saw the opposite in practice
and so this is actually a pretty big
problem because no one would want to use
robust models if they're going to be
less accurate
so i wanted to try to understand like
why this even happens and is there
something we can do that actually uh can
fix this
right so why is there this trade-off
so at a very high level what standard
training does is you take a training
input and then you teach it to get the
correct label like you train a network
to get the right label
when you do robust training you take not
just the input but also set of
perturbations and you force it to get
the right label and all this entire set
of perturbations
so why would adding perturbations uh in
this way increase your standard error
so one natural hypothesis is that
whatever you're adding is actually wrong
right for example if this is what your
data set looked like so you had this
image of a lake and then you had a
perturbation that looks like a laptop
the model correctly called it a laptop
initially but now while doing robustness
you've kind of confused your model then
of course it would make your model less
accurate
but this is not what we expect in
practice because whatever perturbations
we add are actually really small and if
in fact like look like this they're
imperceptible so they're clearly not
adding any inaccurate information
so let's assume for now that whatever
perturbations are accurate and so by
doing this we are strictly you know
giving more information to the model
we're adding more data
so it's very surprising why models would
be less accurate then so maybe this is
because you're adding accurate data but
you don't have enough expressivity
for example if this is a setting where
you only had linear classifiers if you
have to be robust that means you don't
cross any of these boxes then the only
linear class that you could have would
be inaccurate it would be something like
this which is inaccurate
if you want to be robust and accurate
you need this non-linear boundary and so
if you're somehow operating with a model
family that's not rich enough then you
could get these trade-offs
but this is also not true in practice
because we use really big neural
networks first of all and so we assume
they can express such complex function
but also on the training set we observe
that we get zero or like we you know we
we are able to fit the standard and the
perturbations and so we are not in this
kind of a situation we are able to fit
the data
so if you're only adding accurate
information and we also assume that you
know we're well specified we have enough
capacity then it's very surprising why
why would adding more information make
your model worse like make it
generalized worse
and so in some sense we thought this
could be because of poor optimization
because there's no the reason this would
happen
but i think about this more carefully we
found that this trade-off can occur even
in a convex learning problem which i
found quite surprising because it went
completely against my intuition that
telling a model to do something
reasonable actually made it worse
i want to kind of show the simple
construction for where we see this kind
of behavior
so the key thing is we work with over
parameterized models which means that
there are many more parameters than
training points so what this means
intuitively is that there are many ways
to fit the training data so for example
this is what your data set was you could
have all these different classifiers
which all fit your training set
perfectly fine and so the question is
like when you do some kind of estimation
process which of these classifiers does
your model actually pick up
and one way to think about that is to
have this inductive bias or norm and say
that we pick the estimator that fits the
data with minimum norm
so you could have some function that you
defined that helps to disambiguate which
of these ways of fitting the training
data actually is your classifier
and it's also a simple example where
when we use splines where the inductive
bias is to minimize slope changes so you
find the estimator that you know has
fewer slope changes and that's the way
you pick which is your classifier and
how the role of inductive bias can
actually play a role in leading to these
counterintuitive observations
here's a simple construction
so suppose this was your ground truth so
you had two classes and your ground
through the estimator had this kind of
staircase like structure
you could it's a perfectly reasonable
label preserving transformations are
like the ones that are shown here so
these are uh you know perturbations that
should actually preserve your labor
according to ground truth and you try to
induce that in robustness and we can see
what happens
so suppose you had very limited training
data so suppose this was all the
training data that you had let's look at
how standard and robust training perform
so if you did standard training because
you're using splines you're trying to
fit the data with minimum slope changes
so get this blue estimator here which is
the straight line
you can see that it gets the rest of the
line as well correct and it has low
standard error on these like unperturbed
points
but it is not robust like if you
actually draw like you know move things
a little bit like they should have been
the same because the ground truth has
that structure but this classifier would
get it wrong
and now we can try to fix that by doing
robust training which is you know what
we do is we add perturbations our
training time as a way of telling the
model to capture that structure
if you use splines to fit this kind of
new training data set where you've added
data points what you end up is this
green estimator
so
that's the way to fit the training data
while minimizing slope changes
so you can see that this estimator
actually gets the rest of the points
wrong and um so here is an example
where with the best of intentions we
tried to make the model better by giving
it more information
but because of the way the information
was used by the splines model
we actually end up making the model
worse
yeah
changes
but like i could imagine like this
continues as a line that cuts correct
right yeah so i guess that um the
splines estimator doesn't do that i said
the spline will not do it yeah yeah
so one way that i found useful to think
about is that somehow the standard
training captures this global structure
that misses out on this local structure
and we try to
improve the local structure like induce
that by adding training data we ended up
compromising of the global structure
and this is because of using splines
just minimize these slope changes
and we can you know generalize this for
you know for noiseless linear regression
where the common or like the most
standard inductive bias is to minimize
the l2 norm so you fit the data with
minimizing the norm of the estimator
and turns out that a quantity that is
key in determining whether there is a
trade-off or not is a population
covariance
here's an informal theorem where
augmentation or adding the data adding
extra data which is accurate which
shouldn't have hurt your model we can
prove that it does not increase the
standard error or it does what you'd
expect only if either sigma is identity
which means the population covariance is
identity
or you just have a lot of data and the
training data spans all directions of
sigma
so
if you're if you basically see in all
directions of sigma you don't have this
problem or if sigma's identity you don't
have this problem but otherwise you
could be in a situation where adding
data increases your error
and so just like you know passing this
first condition when sigma's identity
basically this geometry kind of matches
the inductive bias which is also
minimizing the l2 norm so if you like if
both of them are basically treating all
directions as equal then there is no
mismatch and there is no uh
counterintuitive trade-offs
so if you take the splines example here
the existence of this global structure
actually makes the covariance very
different from identity and that's why
you could be in danger when you have
something like this
second condition is that the training
data spans all directions so one way to
think about this is if we just had a lot
of training data where we saw everything
that we were to see for example if we
had the entire line then adding
augmentation shouldn't hurt and this is
kind of our usual intuition this would
be like the classical setting where
we're not over parameterized anymore and
so like when you're not over
parameterized any addition of data would
reduce your variance and improve your
estimation and so if you had more
training data then that is actually true
and you can prove that but otherwise you
could be in a danger of
missing or like or like more data
hurting your performance
and so with that intuition we kind of
wanted to see is there a solution that
we could come up with that actually
enables us to use this intuition to
solve things in practice
so if we recall the conditions from the
previous slide we had either limited
training data as an issue or this
mismatched inductive bias we don't have
a good sense of what is inductive bias
of models in practice so it's hard to
try to try to control that but this
training data are something that's
easier to try to fix
so what it says is that if you had limit
if you had more training data there
won't be a trade-off and you try to be
robust and if you try to actually use
this idea that means you should just
collect more data but labels are
expensive
they'd have to go to like you know
download images and like have crowd
workers to label them which is expensive
one thing that we explored is like is
there any way we can get rid of this
labeling part
and turns out that yes unlabeled data
you can prove is actually sufficient to
mitigate this trade-off and that's much
easier to implement because you just
have to like source additional data by
downloading things from the internet we
don't need extra labels
and the algorithm that achieves uh this
you know like mitigates this trade-off
using unlabeled data is robust
self-training
there's a very simple algorithm that
like i'll demonstrate on this particular
example from before
so let's collect a lot of unlabeled data
so we have the same labels as before but
now we've collected a lot of unlabeled
data so we have this black diamond
points whose labels we don't know but we
know they exist
so it's a two-step process and in the
first step we just ignore robustness and
just train a standard classifier so just
take your labels minimize whatever loss
you want normally and use that to get a
classifier
and then generate pseudo labels on the
unlabeled data
so you apply that classifier and
whatever extra
data that you've collected
so doing that here is you have this
straight line that we had before that's
just that's what you would get if you
just minimize the use lines on these
particular points
now we use that to get pseudo labels or
fake labels on this unlabeled data
so so far things have been fine because
you've only captured the global
structure but we still haven't dealt
with robustness so let's deal with that
in the second step but now we perform
robust training on both the labels and
the pseudo labels
so what this means is that you just take
any robust loss earlier you would only
do it on the labels but now you've
generated effectively pseudo labeled
data on the unlabeled extra points that
you had and you do robust training
so doing it here you would introduce
perturbations not just on the labels but
also on the uh pseudo label points
and now when you fit the splines
estimator you get this red line or like
this sorry red estimator which is both
robust and accurate
to summarize this there are two steps
one is just normal standard training on
the labels and then your pseudo label
and then you perform robust training on
effectively a much larger data set
so why does this work like why should
this kind of bootstrapping make sense
the key idea here is that the standard
classifiers which is what we use in the
first step they're very great at pseudo
labeling because the unlabeled data
comes from the same distribution as the
training data
so standard classifiers are only bad on
perturbations they're pretty good on
more unlabeled data from the same
distribution so we can leverage that to
effectively get extra labels for free
and maybe robust training is the harder
statistical problem but really we only
need unlabeled data because we can
generate labels for free
as in this way we found
unlabeled data is especially valuable
for robustness
for example here we had no extra labels
just more unlabeled data we were able to
get both robustness and accuracy by
using this two-step process
and you can prove this in linear
regression that this process would like
always eliminate such trade-offs
and the nice thing is this is a very
simple idea so you can actually
implement this and see what happens and
we did that so we collected more images
which looked like c410 by sourcing it
from the same data set that c410 was
obtained from
and this was the table from before which
i will summarize to make it easier so
if you just didn't vanilla adversarial
training with only labels your standard
error went up and now by using more
unlabeled data you're able to improve
both metrics so
you are actually improving on the
trade-off because
both metrics have improved
so all previous explanations for the
trade-off for like this is inherent and
you're always going to drop but kind of
what we found is that it's actually like
a statistical problem if you just had
more data it seems like please that we
would be able to improve both metrics
and um
so in this talk i only spoke about the
standard error and like you can show a
similar idea like kind of helps for
robustness as well it's like you know
simple
mixture of gaussian setting where there
is a provable lower bound on the sample
complexity needed for robustness you can
prove that actually only unlabeled data
is necessary so
so there's no known example of like a
gap between robustness and accuracy that
unlabeled data cannot solve by this idea
of robust self-training
and the current state of the art as well
as based on this idea it's kind of so
this is roughly where things stand now
so we have improved to some extent over
adversarial training by using more data
to summarize this part in general it's
pretty interesting empirical observation
that is problematic in that every time
we want to improve robustness the most
natural thing you try to do is to add
more data to reflect the structure you
want to capture but that could actually
make your model less accurate because of
these kind of inductive bias issues with
large models
but the nice thing is that we're just
using extra unlabeled data and this
robust self-training you are able to
mitigate some of these issues which
scales up in practice as well
and so to reflect on this part a little
bit and stuff that we don't completely
understand one thing that i found
interesting is that
so far like this whole analysis studied
of noiseless setting so we assume
there's no noise in the data and if we
were in the under parameterized setting
where like the number of data points was
more than dimensions if you're in a
noiseless setting you basically solve
the problem but interestingly when
you're in the over parameterized regime
which is where like a lot of neural
networks we think are even noiseless
setting can give you pretty interesting
observations especially because in
practice the labels are typically pretty
like they seem pretty correct
and of course you know over
parameterization kind of blurs the line
between generalization in distribution
and extrapolation because if you assume
there are like some directions or
dimensions that you just haven't seen
like do you call that generalization or
extra or extrapolation is kind of
unclear so that's something that i feel
like you know this example
went over because we didn't even
construct a particular distribution
and in general and think about
robustness so we care about structure of
perturbations relative to the data
distribution
and we need to be careful about like
what exactly is the structure of
perturbations and how does it relate to
the original distribution sort of oops
um sort of i guess i don't have time so
i'll skip that part but in in my work
what i found was pretty helpful to deal
with this thing is to assume the least
possible you can about robustness which
is that it is just anything that's
orthogonal to the subspace of your
training data kind of falls under the
robustness so it feels like that was one
way that we found useful even for
real-world distribution shifts where we
had no way of characterizing what the
shifts were as a conceptual mathematical
model thinking of robustness as just
orthogonal to your training data was
something that was pretty helpful
i guess with that i will stop because i
don't have
time but
yeah
and i think in general like a lot of
there's just a lot of open problems like
we don't know how to solve robustness in
practice and some of like you know in my
work i've made really really simple
assumptions or like done very little
modeling of what the data distribution
or the perturbations are and i've still
found pretty useful insights and so if
you can actually do more careful
analysis of like these worst case
distributions and perturbations and what
role the data distribution plays i think
we could get really useful things that
could help us solve these problems in
practice
yeah with that i want to thank google
and open philanthropy for
funding me in this work and my wonderful
collaborators
[Applause]
great yeah thanks to dj for the very
great talk uh any other questions
you is it is it you said at some point
that uh all all the lp based methods are
beat by
stps like are
okay i mean uh to what extent is their
flexibility to design bigger lps i mean
somehow lp solver there should be some
tradeoff here like lp solvers are
probably a lot faster than stp solver so
you could imagine designing fancier lps
than the obvious one have people tried
uh sort of fancifying the lps instead of
switching to quadratic programs yeah i
think there's one work that i can point
you to that um characterizes more
generally what is the class of lps for
which there is this kind of barrier so
it's not just the vanilla lp but like
you can't construct fancier things but i
think you're still limited by the fact
that
so i think the main issue with okay so
the main intuition for why lps fail is
that you have all these different nodes
in the network and the in linear
programs you can only end up analyzing
the nodes kind of independently like
there's no way to talk about how
one activation compares to like how it
how it affects the other activation
because that would make things quadratic
um
and so in some sense that was like
that's the intuition for why there is
this gap so any linear program kind of
doesn't cannot reason about things
jointly
or that's why
okay a related question when you
work in in the quadratic um formulation
so you you actually introduce like pairs
of variables like there's every every
pair of activations gets a variable
uh yes
you i mean so that okay the reason i'm
asking this is because there are
there are these works like okay there's
some paper by uh andrea's group
montanari
where they were thinking about how to
implement degree 4 sos for some
image denoising tasks
and the observation was well for imaging
noising you only sort of like okay
degree for sos sounds prohibitive but
you only need like to really preserve
some local constraints because there's
locality right and okay you would think
deep nuts would have a similar
phenomenon that like you know this act i
should i should care about the joint
behavior of this activation and ones
near it but do i care about the behavior
the joint behavior of this activation
one's far away like do you really need
all all pairs of variables in your
quadratic program that's a good question
yeah i
yeah that's a i don't i can't say for
sure yes so we haven't looked at that i
think that's a good idea yeah okay okay
i think what most matter is if you have
like things in the same layer
yeah so i think you want to reason about
things in the same layer jointly because
they all feed into one node well like
maybe like between layers you probably
you might get away with not modeling
that so yeah they're all getting into
one note in some sense they're close
right there yeah exactly yeah exactly
yeah yeah
great other questions
um if not let's thank aditi again thank
you
so we're back at 3 30.